so I am so excited to be here and I am
so excited to talk to you about I am you
I will tell you what they are but what
is the backstory behind this like why am
I dressed up this way so in 2018
Halloween a few months ago I was like I
need a Halloween costume I'm really
excited and you know what I'm really
excited about magic because I am a
programmer and I can do magic and Harry
Potter is also magic so maybe I can do a
programming thing at a magic thing and a
Harry Potter thing so specifically when
I was a kid there was this game that I
really liked Harry Potter and you would
go around in this game and you would
have a magic wand and you would wave
your wand at things and you would like
do these various gestures and you could
like make things float you could stun
things you could unlock things it was
awesome and I was like I would really
like to have this in real life so I did
it and it was awesome and yeah I really
enjoyed it and just to give a little bit
of context there were a few logistical
constraints behind this project because
I was like thought about doing this like
around early October I had about two to
three weekends and I was like I want to
spend less than $200 on this so those
were the constraints I was under so I
was like okay well I can work with this
so let me go through like how to build
like my gesture recognition one so when
you do a gesture recognition one you
have like three different components you
have your algorithms which is software
and then you have your computer running
your algorithms and then you have that
your sensor which is also hardware and
so it's these three pieces combined so
first let's talk about the software
aspect of the things like the algorithms
cool so how does kind of your standard
gesture recognition algorithm work so
what happens is you get time series data
so the x-axis on this graph is basically
time and you just have a while loop that
just runs forever and it's just like
eating this data and you're like hmm
like I see this like slice of data is
there a gesture here hmm is there no
there isn't hmm is there data here nope
no gesture and you just keep going and
then you get here and it's really
exciting there's a thing here and you
run your same algorithm and you're like
yes there is a gesture here trigger the
gesture thing awesome and then you know
you it's a while loop so you like keep
going forever so that's your really high
level algorithm awesome we know what our
algorithm is going to be next what
talk a little bit about sensors so there
are a lot of different sensors that you
can use for a project like this what I
decided to use was an IMU which stands
for inertial measurement unit it's
basically an orientation sensor it has
an ax seller ometer a gyroscope and a
magnetometer and all you really have to
know is it tracks like your position
like this is a rabbit being tracked by
IMU and it can detect like shakiness it
can detect your like direction of north
it can detect how you're like twisting
things it can detect a lot of awesome
things so I'm like okay I am used this
seems awesome how do I find an IMU
because I'm doing a hardware project
fortunately there's this awesome website
Adafruit and I went in and I like typed
in I am you and it came up here is an
IMU you can use and I'm like awesome
this is great there are libraries for it
there are tutorials for how to wire
stuff up
I like this documentation it's great so
now I know what sensor I'm going to use
and finally what computer am I use going
to use what am I going to use to like
connect all of this and make it all work
well so when you're doing these kinds of
like hardware electronics projects there
are two large categories of computers
that you can choose so on one hand you
can use embedded Linux so this is your
like Raspberry Pi and on the other hand
you can use like microcontrollers which
are kind of Arduino like systems and
these boards look pretty similar but
they're surprisingly different and the
main difference is your razz pi loves
Linux and I love Linux and specifically
like why why do I love Linux well
because on the res PI I get my Python I
get my scikit-learn so my standard
machine learning stuff I get my
tensorflow
or is on microcontrollers on the support
machine for machine learning is a little
bit less mature you're like hmm maybe I
can use micro Python like I've seen some
hacks for like getting tensorflow to run
on microcontrollers but like I have two
to three weeks and I do not have time to
like figure out how to like do snake
charming or Parseltongue on like a
microcontroller so I'm just going to go
with like a rasp I unfortunately like
the standard rasp eyes like the size of
two of my fists and like this is my wand
it's pretty small and I'm like I need a
small Raz PI so I like type into Google
small R as PI and like this Raz PI comes
up and I'm like awesome I have a small R
as PI so cool now I know like a rough
Algar
I have my small res pie and I have my
like I am you that I looked up on
Adafruit cool now that I have these
pieces I need to put them together so
the first part like I just follow the
tutorial and I connect my I am you to my
rasp I cuz documentation is great and
the communication protocol is UART and
I'm like I need to attach this to a wand
somehow actually first I need to like
have a wand and do I make it by hand
I actually I so I just went to Amazon
and I like Google like custom one and
like this came up and I'm like awesome
this seems super easy and I like order
to wand so I like took this and I like
glued it to a wand and I was like yes
I'm done except batteries are not
included I'm like oh I need a battery so
I like went and I bought a battery and I
could I connected it to the Raz PI and
then I was like things well when I
detect the gesture like something needs
to happen like do I want my like lights
to turn on do I like want to like build
this giant fan thing till I blow all my
pillows and like have them float I have
two to three weeks so I'm just going to
play a sound effect so I ended up buying
like a speaker so this is a speaker and
I just connected over USB audio so great
I finally have my thing and like how
this this is like a software engineer
trying to do like mechanical diagrams so
this so I basically I have this wand one
and then I have the battery and one of
the most amazing things I realized was
after I ordered the battery I was like
the battery is the size same diameter as
the wand so I just like glued them
together and then I like hold it and
it's great and then on top of this I
have the R as PI zero and then I have
the IMU and I'm like I need to attach
this together you know what's good at
like tying things together hair ties so
I like tied it together with hair ties
and it was great and then finally you're
like okay but like my speaker is huge
like what do I do with this well
fortunately like I'm wearing this robe
and like the sleeves are like really big
so I can just like thread it up my
sleeve and the kids won't notice because
all I have to do is impress the kids
star on Halloween cool so this is this
is a picture of the completed product
you can see like a big picture at the
left and on the right it was actually
like you know what
we're awesome the normal hair ties clear
hair ties so like that's why I like you
can like see the nice R as pie and
everything cool and I was able to kind
of have a successful Halloween which was
super fun and I really enjoyed it and um
you know in our remaining time I'd love
to talk a little bit more about how to
that you can do this yourself how you
can get into hardware prototyping so for
a long time like I really wanted to do
Hardware prototyping but I couldn't get
into it and what I realized is there are
certain mind shifts that you have to
make in order to jump from software to
hardware so one of the things that I
realized is that you need to have a lot
more discipline and you need to really
kind of work on your planning skills
because when you're doing software
you're like yes hackathon download all
the things right now but when you doing
a hardware project you can't be like
order all the things right now except
you can but you're still going to have
to wait for shipping and that goes into
my next point which is one of the things
I didn't realize doing hardware projects
is you're going to be a lot faster if
you just order all the things and then a
cept that you're only going to use half
of them this is kind of like your R&D
budget like in software your R&D budget
is time and hardware your R&D budget is
also money and it's just a lot more fun
when there's no pressure to like choose
all your parts carefully so once I made
this mind shift it was a lot easier to
kind of go into this but another thing
that also really helps with getting into
hardware prototyping as having more
reference projects and having more
documentation so in the light of
documentation I actually have all the
software for this project on my github
software documentation and on the
hardware side of things I want one of
the things I dislike about hardware
projects is people are like let's talk
about like the big pieces of it and like
you'll figure out the cable things by
yourself and I was like I don't like
this like so I made this Amazon wishlist
that has all the cables I used all the
parts I use even like the superglue I
use so you can just go to this link um
this link is also on the github so you
don't have to copy it down the github
also has a link to the slide deck but
you can just like order all the things
and it includes all the cables
unfortunately it doesn't include all the
tools so you're going to need a
soldering iron it's not on that list but
we're just about out of time
and
there are so many other things I am
excited about that I want to talk to you
guys about so like please find me
afterward or like email or tweet me if
you would like to talk about any of
these things or other things or like
tools or basically all the things so
thank you so much really enjoy being
here and looking forward to an awesome
bing bang con West
[Applause]